All right, let's talk to some folks from the
audience to hear what is on folks minds.
Another very busy week of news with more upcoming
and many different things going on, including
great news on vaccinations, covid cases declining,
but still many challenges ahead and so many
different things going on.
We will do it via discord, as we have been
doing for several months.
And it is working.
It's working well, I would say David Pakman
dot com slash discord.
Let's go first to Anna from Vietnam, Anna
from Vietnam.
You're on the air.
Oh, hello, yes, how are you?
I'm so I'm sorry I'm getting so nervous.
Oh, please don't be nervous.
Are you?
I'm nervous because we've never had a caller
from Vietnam before.
Yeah, I'm nervous because this is the first
time I've ever made a call to anyone.
Kind of famous before, oh, I was I thought
you were going to say this is the first time
you've ever spoken to anyone via digital means,
I was going to be surprised that we are.
So what's going on?
What what can I do for you, Anna?
But, yeah, I have heard and I've seen in some
social media that there's been an uprising,
racism against Asian people in the U.S.. Yes.
So I want to know if you acknowledge that.
And I want to know what are your thoughts
about it, I guess.
Yeah, I believe that.
I mean, listen, I have no personal I follow
the science and the data and a number of well-respected
organizations that track hate incidents have
seen that since the start of the pandemic
in the United States.
There have been significantly larger numbers
of hate incidents against Asian folks up believed
and to be because Donald Trump kept talking
about China, China, China, the China virus,
the Choung Flu, et cetera, et cetera.
So I think that I mean, my view is that it's
disgusting and it's despicable and that we
should be able to simultaneously say China's
not being transparent.
We have a diplomatic problem with China without
fomenting random attacks on Asian people in
the street.
You know, these are two different things.
It's disgusting.
Yeah, I understand, and yeah, I just want
to make sure that we are not like.
Being so conflicting on this, I know that
is not the best source to get your information
from from social media in general, because
I have a lot of people having.
My actual thoughts about it, the science of
in paperwork, things like that, but to be
able to have is so obvious that even the sources
that are not supposed to give you, like, specific
and very accurate information about it, like
talking about it is quite huge.
And to me, the America has always been a place
where you can be free and achieve your American
dream.
So to see that happening to my people is very
upsetting and very unsettling.
In a way.
I completely agree with you and understand
how horrible that must be.
And you speak beautiful English.
How would tell us about how did you learn
English in school in Vietnam?
Ow, ow, ow, ow.
So this because, yeah, I formulated my thoughts
before calling, oh, OK.
But I'm getting like nervous laugh I know
you're doing great.
You're doing great.
Anna, listen, I wish my American callers took
a moment to formulate their thoughts before
they called.
They could really take a lesson from.
My pleasure.
Anna, thank you, Anna, from Vietnam as close
to a perfect phone call as I can imagine.
Let's go next to Jared from New York.
Jared, you're on the air.
Hey, David, I know you've interviewed Ken
Jennings in the past, which was real cool.
Yeah, it was for people who don't know the
many, many time winner of Jeopardy.
Yes.
I was wondering if you've seen any of new
episodes where he's taken over as host and
if you have any thoughts on kind of how he's
done or what they're going to be doing, what
they're going to be bringing on guest host.
So I just wondered if you had any thoughts.
No, I haven't seen an episode of Jeopardy
in probably a decade, and I haven't watched
a live TV show as it's airing other than sports
or news for almost as long.
So I have no I didn't even know he was hosting
Jeopardy, to be quite honest.
Yeah, he he took over on an interim basis.
And it's interesting.
It's tough because it's it's hard to kind
of get used to his style after seeing Alex
or so long.
But yeah, that's all I just wanted to get.
Say, are you like I know that Jeopardy!
Fans are very adamant, like they they watch
every episode.
Has this been a huge thing in the jeopardy
community?
Oh, yeah, it's been a very big thing.
It's just there's a lot of discussions of
is it is people find it a little odd, but
is it because they're not used to it?
Is it because he's just new and he'd have
to get more comfortable or is it because he's
just not a great host?
Interesting.
Oh, everybody.
And the guests coming up are interesting.
It's people like Anderson Cooper will be guest
hosting and Katie Couric.
But then you have Aaron Rodgers, who's an
NFL quarterback.
So they're taking an interesting approach.
I would like to guest host.
Maybe we can get a campaign going.
I would be interested in doing that.
That would be really cool for sure.
All right.
Well, let's let's make it happen.
It sounds like you're kind of an insider in
this community.
I think you have the power.
Absolutely.
Absolutely right.
OK, thanks, Jared from New York.
And I'm not kidding.
I expect to hear from you about guest hosting